and to Washington where former Twitter
Executives were pressed during a
combative Congressional hearing and they
admitted there were mistakes in blocking
a New York Post story about the
president's son Hunter Biden just before
the 2020 election however they denied
that they were pressured to do so senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge has more for us now Catherine
good morning Good morning Tony this was
the first major public hearing for the
republican-led house oversight committee
to focus on President Biden and his
family with new hands on subpoena power
we're likely to see more demands for
records soon
with limited information Twitter made a
mistake former Twitter Executives told
Congress the social media platform was
wrong to suppress the New York Post
reporting on Hunter Biden's laptop ahead
of the 2020 election in hindsight
Twitter should have reinstated the post
account immediately Witnesses testified
they wanted to avoid a repeat of the
2016 presidential race it's pretty clear
you won't admit the Russians have
engaged in cyber attacks when Russian
intelligence was blamed for hacking and
sharing emails from then candidate
Hillary Clinton and the Democratic
National Committee Twitter noticed
activity related to the laptop that at
first glance bore a lot of similarities
to the 2016 Russian Hack and leak
operation our judgment was colored by
the experience of 2016. the former
Twitter Executives included James Baker
who is the FBI's top lawyer under then
director James Comey he denied Twitter's
decisions were dictated by The Bureau
sitting here today I don't recall
speaking to the FBI at all about the
hunter Biden matter or the Biden
campaign did anyone from the Biden
campaign or the Democratic National
Committee direct Twitter to remove or
take action against the New York Post
story no Mr Baker same question to you
please
not to my knowledge no after the hearing
chairman Comer told CBS News his
investigators are pivoting to the Biden
family's finances For the First Time The
Republican control committee has
officially requested records and
Communications from Hunter Biden James
the president's brother and their
business manager once you've
demonstrated a sincere
effort to obtain this information and
they refuse to comply then you can take
it to the next step which would be a
subpoena
did not rule out subpoenas as early as
April CBS News reached out to the
parties and lawyers for Hunter Biden for
comment and there was no immediate
response Dana
all right Catherine thank you